et en france l'ambassadeur de russie a
également participé aux festivités dans
la matinée il a déposé une couronne de
fleurs au pied du monument aux morts qui
rend hommage aux participants soviétique
dans la résistance française une statue
située au cimetière du père lachaise
dans le 20e arrondissement de la
capitale
pour alexeï guskov la participation des
résistants soviétique a été décisive
pour vaincre le nazisme et le fascisme y
acheter je pense que c'est notre
victoire commune donc les français
célèbrent tout d'abord leur victoire ils
ont aussi participer avec nous à cette
guerre à foz la diaspora russe déploie
tous les efforts possibles pour que les
célébrations du jour de la victoire soit
à la hauteur
les prisonniers de guerre soviétiques
les résistants soviétiques ont apporté
une contribution importante à la
victoire sur le fascisme en france il
faisait partie de ce vaste groupe
réunissant quarante mille personnes et
représentant 17 nations dix sept pays
qui combattent est ici mode dans la mort
avec leurs frères français contre le
fascisme et leurs noms sont inscrits en
lettres d'or dans l'histoire française